a man with 3-time NBA champion in his 11
years in the NBA now is the EVP and
managing executive of the Wasserman
Media Group he is none other than BJ
Armstrong how are you sir I'm rich how
are you I'm doing great I'm doing great
like again I was saying to Kris and to
the folks in the first segment as I said
to you backstage
we were thinking okay who can talk about
3p ting and shooting and kur and Jordan
and and the possibility of the Warriors
either being broken up by free agency or
sticking around then this guy you who's
been on both ends of playing an agent
thing so thank you for being nice of you
to think of me I don't know if I can
talk about it but look I mean you you
definitely have a lot of experience with
your you've got a lot of fingers in a
lot of pots here so let's start with the
the Warriors and what Kerr said about
Durant that the last time he saw
somebody in a role like this was named
Michael and he had fun with saying he
doesn't remember his last name what do
you what do you think of of that
statement BJ well you know when you
think of an offensive player
who has the capability of a Jordan where
you said you know what you're gonna pick
and choose when to implement them in the
offense you know at the time Phil
Jackson was running an offense triangle
offense and we just picked and choose
where to put Jordan did you put him on
the strong side the weak side but most
importantly where we're gonna get on the
ball in an operating area when I watch
Kevin Durant now this year unlike in
years past Kevin Durant is playing the
game with the ability to score with a
live dribble he's catching the ball in
an operating area like Jordan did and
there aren't many players who can do
that Kevin Durant is really he's showing
me something I haven't really seen
before he's always open every time he
catches the ball because he's seven feet
he doesn't have to make a move and that
to me gives him a significant advantage
as an offensive player because he
doesn't really have to do anything other
than catch the ball square up get in a
good offensive position and rise up rise
up and above and shoot you know Petra
Beverley and all those guys within the
last series they did everything they
could possibly do but because of his
height he's automatically getting a good
look at the basket yeah it was funny
there was a there was a postgame press
conference I wonder if you saw it after
Game six did you
yes did you see this Chris when it was
Beverly and Mo Williams together and
somebody asked them like could you what
else could what more could you have done
to stop Durant and they basically just
said what do you you don't think we you
know we tried everything and they just
they couldn't have been more truthful
like that he's unstoppable is basically
he really is I mean because of his
height I mean really I can't think of
any player other than maybe George
Gervin who was six seven at the two
position but Kevin Durant is every bit
seven feet you know he's a seven-foot
player who was playing the game as a
guard and he catches the ball in an
operating area is not what you really
can do well when you say that catch a
ball in an operating area is this
something that you see again from your
time with Phil knowing what Steve Kerr
might have taken from that is do you see
the X's and O's of what kurz doing to
get him in these operating right I
really do i I think the the great thing
as Steve has learned is how to implement
very talented players into a system and
I think that is a as a talent as a coach
you know you don't see it varied off
very often I think I saw with Chuck Daly
I saw with Pat Riley I've seen it now
with Gregg Popovich when you implement
you know attempt Duncan into the team
and now you're seeing now with Steve
Kerr what he's doing with Kevin Durant
Kevin Durant is a very special
individual talent that is somehow
someway they've been able to implement
that talent into the team without taking
away from everything of what a team
brings but also a great individual
player like him BJ Armstrong here on the
Rich Eisen show so how how does this
team get stomped
I mean how does this team get stopped
understand that is a tough question I
think one of the keys is you know first
you got to figure out what are you gonna
do with draymond Green draymond Green to
me is a player that you have to take
into the same regard if you're if you're
game planning against the Warriors like
you did with those Bulls teams with
Scottie Pippen because draymond Green
has the ability to distribute and
organize an offense and you put two if
you put two shooters in the corners for
him and a player that you can play over
the top
it really makes him a very effective
offensive player because he's the best
screener on the team I think that's the
first thing the second thing which is
easier said than done is you're going to
have to get to their bench their bench
you know Steve Kerr has really
Gordon his rotations even though there
are they are you know they're up 200 in
this series he's really shorten his
rotation so I think at some point if
you're gonna beat this team you're gonna
have to get the game five six and seven
right because they're playing a lot of
minutes their starters this is a
top-heavy team right now and I think if
you can get to their bench to get their
bench to play some extended minutes I
think it increases your chance to win
that game so let's take that one piece
of the time your answer there BJ cuz
anybody that watches this team just as a
fan sitting on the couch yes would say
okay who do you have to stop in order to
beat this team Draiman would be choice
for you know with right khari shooting
from the logo and the pick and roll or
durant shooting from 3-point or driving
as you pointed out he's playing a seven
footer as a seven footer playing like a
guard klay Thompson wide open deadly
he's got a flamethrowers we were and
then you say dream on so why why why
dream on okay but dream on organizes the
game for the rest of the players okay
he's the best screener on the team okay
he's the best distributor and he
distributes to all of the other guys you
know dream are we'll pass up a shot
throw an alley-oop to Andre Iguodala
right now you know to the obviou to the
to the you know person just watching the
game ago a it has a nice plate but
draymond is he's continuing to
distribute which makes the defensive
rotations and very difficult to get into
I would focus in on draymond first and
make him into a scorer just do the
Rockets have that player no one's
figured it out
dream on dream on at the center position
is a very very unique player he's a very
unique player because how many other
centers can rebound the ball
push it up on the break and distribute
and make the right play and he does this
consistently night in and night out how
many other teams have the luxury to run
their offense through their Center and
know that the ball will get to where it
needs to get to at the right time so
draymond has mastered the art if you
will knowing when to shoot and win the
pass and that to me is a key to any
offense because you have players who can
get the ball where it needs to get to at
the right time and I've
she has great shooters - get it - buddy
give draymond the credit he's getting it
to the right people at the right time
and it reminds me of Scottie Pippen
Scottie Pippen's greatest asset was
getting the ball to where it needed to
get to at any moment during the course
of a game thank you so kid you know
crush you off the dribble he could he
could just destroy you
he's well absolutely I mean he just
plays with options draymond plays with
options and if you're going to play
against this team you got to take away
something you know when I look at the
game last night the Warriors have made a
definite effort to take away the
alley-oop option Clint capela you don't
see Clint capela flying in in you know
just getting you know Ali abducts now at
some point the Houston Rockets are gonna
have to take away something they're
gonna have to take away something from
draymond book a draymond right now is
picking them apart he's thrown it to
clay he's thrown it to stuff he's thrown
it - to Kevin Durant who's that is it PJ
Tucker I mean who can do that who can
guard dream on in that regard well most
of time because he's playing the center
position you guard him with the your
center so I think you guard him with
speed and quickness the game now is
about speed and quickness draymond as a
sinner is a definite advantage to the
Warriors because he plays the game and
make allows them to play faster you know
this is the first team really if you
look at the Rockets the Warriors can
play just as fast or faster than them
normally they're the fastest team in the
league right with draymond at the center
position I would argue that the Warriors
are faster than them because draymond
has the ability to push the ball on the
break just as well as any guard mm-hmm
so this is a problem I think that no one
has solved yet and I think it's kind of
caught up the Rockets by surprise if you
just watch the game from a technical
standpoint because what they're able to
do and how quickly they're doing it you
know they're scoring now I think last
night was one of the unique things I've
seen in a while
the Rockets court on the other end and
the the Warriors came down and score
without the ball touching the floor and
dunked it on the other end that's very
hard to do especially in the playoffs so
the Warriors are committed to playing
the game as fast as they can because
they have the players and the personnel
to do it Vijay Armstrong here on the
Rich Eisen show and yet though you would
say that the bench is thin yes this is a
personnel to do it
is that why you think they signed boogie
cousins in the offseason and now that's
coming home to roost that they thought
they would have him to not have to play
the Hamptons 5 off the top you know I
mean and just stick with them and have
them all log 35 40 minutes in a
seven-game slog of a series well when
you're playing year in and year out in
the playoffs at the length of time it's
just gonna wear on you right and I think
signing boogie was a huge advantage for
them it was a huge asset for them
because they had an able body and
allowed them to play in a way that you
know what if the game got slow right
you could play slow I think the the you
know and watching them boogie was really
gonna be the player that they wanted to
anchor their second unit because if you
can run the offense through boogie from
the post in the same way that they run
it through draymond yes I think it
allows you to kind of settle that second
eunuch in because you need a score on
your second unit so I think that was the
the thought process when they signed
boogie and they need in another body but
when you take away boogie now is forcing
their starters to play extended minutes
and I think at some point it probably
will catch up with them but certainly
they look good in the first two games
and then in terms of BG Armstrong again
here on the Rich Eisen show okay now put
on your agent in hand okay let's do it
so July 1st rolls around I said at the
top of the show these guys would be
crazy to leave each other I mean this is
as special as it gets right now but you
as somebody and it's interesting that
you talk dream on up and people would
say hey well that's his agent talking
right now you no longer represent that's
correct okay so knowing though the
mindset of dream on as you do and
knowing what it's like to try and keep a
team together as you do from many
different angles right what do you what
do you think happens July 1st with this
team well I think this team has been
together long enough now to where they
are a team now that people that played
and won have success what is the one
thing that breaks all championship teams
up it's the me factor it's me mm-hm you
know how important am i I think that is
one thing they're all gonna have to
assess once the season is over with
clearly they have very special players
clearly they can play together as a
group
but I think the the me factor you've
been around each other for so long you
began your mind begins to wonder I think
at some point they will all realize
hopefully sooner rather than later how
important how much they need each other
but I think if they are going to move
okay I think if that does happen or that
comes into play I think many of them
will begin to think about what could I
do and where can I begin to expand my
role you know I think in particular
Kevin Durant what is the next step for
Kevin Durant is to we can say he's a
great player we can say he came in he
integrated his you know his talent into
that team but was he the leader of that
team and I think if he looks at it from
that standpoint maybe that's something
he wants to do maybe that is a challenge
that he thinks that's next in his career
who knows but I think that is something
that all of them all of the players are
going to have to figure out what what
does this team gonna look like moving
forward in the foreseeable future well
but I mean let's be honest here what
better legacy is there in the win four
in a row or five in a row or six in a
row
what better legacy could you possibly
have unless you're sitting there and
actually hearing people say well you had
nothing to do with it specific you
weren't Jordan you weren't like right
the end don't like that the the universe
didn't revolve around you you join the
universe but at this point three years
later he's as integral part of this team
as as any in Kevin Durant so I ask you
this as an agent the stories that are
out there right now let's say he's
decided he's going to New York
or he's leaving he needs to go to spot
to create his own legacy and he's
playing basketball right now knowing
that he's leaving the Warriors we have
heard stories out there that he's even
contacted a team to say he's coming and
we all assume that's the Knicks you as
an agent and somebody who knows what
it's like to negotiate and go into free
agency how real is that a possibility
right now well I think that's very
difficult to play knowing that you're
already out I think that's very very
hard to do because you have to be
invested as of you know athlete I'll put
my you know former athletic hat back on
being in the game you have to be
invested into the now and every athlete
understands that who especially plays
the game at the level that he's planted
you don't
one foot out of the door and then you're
playing at the level he's planning
playing at currently as you see Kevin
day Kevin Durant is playing the game as
high a level as I've seen right I think
as an agent you have to be prepared for
all just like when I worked in the front
office for a team you have to be
prepared for all scenarios if you don't
do that you're not doing your job so I
think it is in an in his best interest
to be prepared I think his agent will be
prepared I think the team will be
prepared but I don't think that decision
will be made until after the season is
over all right you can sit down look at
the situation evaluate the situation and
see the landscape of where the league is
at because you know you know he knows
what he has there but now he has to see
or and make an educated decision on
where the league is gonna be and what
that's going to see and what's that's
gonna look for him or look like for him
in the future but I you know I'm not
saying that you would do this or you
operate in this manner with the
Wasserman Media Group but is it feasible
that an agent could tell a team in the
middle of a playing season he's coming I
mean is that possible anything is
possible
um but I you know how could you do that
you know you don't know where the draft
is you know you have injuries you have
so many things you don't have control
over right but anything is possible yes
that is possible do I see that being in
this league now for 30-something years
no because you have to let the chips
fall you have to let the chips kind of
play themselves out you have to let the
game play itself out and really see
where how things are gonna look once you
have to get to that decision what do you
think draymond decision has in front of
him knowing him if you don't mind me
well I am in a former car I think I
think with any player especially a
player of that level you is always gonna
be based on performance you know dream
on is always a player that has performed
he's a big game player the bigger the
moment the bigger he plays and one thing
I've always admired about him then and I
and I respected now is he plays in chaos
the more chaotic the situation is the
better he is when all of that was
swirling around with the referees after
game 1 the first thing I said was dream
on is gonna have a great game in crane
too because he plays in chaos
functions better in chaos that's some
players you know there's things going on
and they get distracted the more chaos
going on around Rhema the better he is
he can quiet his mind he can quiet the
game and he can play in this so more
things you're talking about he's gonna
be better and better because he just
plays in big moment but isn't it so let
me take this this way you can be great
in chaos if the way that you play the
game in chaos lands in the hands of
other guys named curry and Durant and
clay you know what I mean life where if
you go to a new situation and you're
creating the chaos and it takes a while
to build a championship team because
you're going to a new situation suddenly
the chaos will as an opportunity to
totally consume you and you might go to
a coach that when they're they zoom in
on his lips and he says I'm so sick and
tired of this person's you know what you
don't have that relationship yet and you
don't have the winning of surrounding it
to spray that deodorant over the
situation yes so is he thinking do you
think about like this doesn't work for
me anymore even though I'm explaining
what might actually work for him right
now cuz he wants his own situation well
you know if you're if you're saying
basically what you're saying is dream is
he a player that can go out and score 20
points consistently every night in this
league no I don't think that's his game
I think draymond what he does is he
brings chemistry to your team he does
all of the little things and he does
things to help you win basketball games
that's what he does he's won at every
level high school collegiate pros that's
what he does draymond Green plays
winning basketball now if you force him
to be a player where suddenly we're
gonna ask him to score 20 25 points a
night I don't think that's his game I
think he will tell you that's not this
game so the combination of what he
brings has to be valued playing winning
basketball because playing winning
basketball is different than playing
basketball when you're just trying to
get to the playoffs or you're just
trying to stay you know above water he
is an excellent fit for a team that is
ready and prepared to win games because
of his knowledge what he brings and all
of the intangibles that he brings to a
group all right couple more minutes left
with BJ Armstrong here on the Rich Eisen
show so
did the me take the Bulls down with
Jordan go and play baseball or the me
never took the Bulls down when you
played them let's stop yeah you know
what I I think what took us down was the
the pressure you will of just performing
night in and night out in particular
Michael because you know there's a lot
of pressure in when you're carrying a
team like he was carrying you know that
group it just took a pressure not only
on the court off the court and I think
there was the circumstances that were
going on at that particular time and his
in his you know in his life you know he
had some things going on but I think
physically it just takes a toll and
watching this Warriors team you know
going back to what's going on now I
think at some point playing you know 25
or 30 games or whatever you're planning
the playoffs takes its toll because
you're playing in a condensed amount of
time at a higher level and I think
physically mentally emotionally it just
takes a toll on you I think that's what
happened to us and Michael stepped away
from the game came back and he was
reenergized when he came back I think he
saw the joy in which he was playing the
game because sometime you just keep
doing it over and over again you kind of
get into a rut and I think him stepping
away gave him the energy or the
resurgence that he needed to continue
doing he needed to do it so when you
look at this Warriors team right now 10
wins away from a three-peat yes and you
see the coach you know the coach I know
what the coach knows you know the
coaches experiences that he brings from
the X's and O's to his own playing
experience to keeping a three-peat team
together all of that the the the minutes
that these guys are logging and the
impending free agency market that you
know well he has an agent what do you
see here do you see a team that's at the
end of a run or a team that kinds of a
great front office and ownership that's
gonna get together with a new arena
opening up and figure out how to keep
everyone happy and at the feeding trough
and keep this thing going what do you
see right now BJ Armstrong well you know
first as I watched you know coach Kerr
and Steve and you know call him coach
card this makes me laugh as I watch
coach Kerr I see a coach who he's fouled
his space
- never trust happiness can't be happy
in this league and continue to do what
you're doing you have to be even killed
and I think that's what he's done
probably better this year than any other
year is he doesn't trust the happiness
he's not trusting that he's up to oh and
has control of this of this series he
knows how quickly things can turn as you
saw in the last series with the LA
Clippers things can turn in a hurry
during the playoffs I think in the
foreseeable future with this team is
they're going to have to address
long-term is how they're going to build
a team because financially they have
some things they have to work out I mean
you got a Kevin Durant klay Thompson
draymond up and then what is that gonna
leave for the other guys to build out a
roster that compete that can't compete
at a high level for the next to three to
four years so I think that is going to
be an issue for this team moving forward
is financially is how are they gonna
build a team and obviously you need
great players obviously you need talent
obviously you need tough players to do
it but again financially how do you
spread that out through the court you
know through ten eleven twelve players
is it gonna be the big question so do
you see this winding down so we're
saying I think it's gonna be very
difficult for them I think at some point
age and time is gonna come into play
here and you know do you want to have a
33 34 year old player you know at that
number and being able to build and and
saying do we have a realistic chance to
compete at that level at that age and
those are questions they're gonna have
to answer so I think it's it's a real
conversation they have to have and it'd
be interesting to see what they do well
we went on so long about all this I'd
love to keep you one more segment if I
can to talk about the shooting fouls and
the shooters and landing areas and all
of that stuff BJ Armstrong is going to
stick around for one more segment here
the EVP and managing executive of the
Wasserman Media Group and three-time NBA
champion in his own right that's next
year on the Rich Eisen show BJ Armstrong
three-time NBA champion back here for
one more segment that's way game one
ended of the series that's now two old
warriors let's put your shooting hat on
okay what's a foul anymore with a
three-point shot landing areas and
things like that do you think that these
were good non
in game 1 do you think that the landing
areas were being broach do you think
that hardens kicking out what do you
think right here BJ well I think as the
game has changed the way the game is
refereed has changed clearly in in my
era when I played that was a foul the
way the game is played today you know I
think the the the psyche or the way the
way you defend a 3-point shot has
changed at one point we closed out the
three-point shooters now you're trying
to run guys off the line I think the
referees now have to make they have to
be consistent in the way they're gonna
call the game moving forward the
consistency in the whistle has to be
there so that the players can adapt to
how the game is gonna be played but
clearly in the way that I think and I
think most people when they see that
they see contact and that should be a
foul because the thing that we don't
want as players and as coaches and
people who watched again you don't want
to see players get injured and a player
is very vulnerable when they rise up to
shoot and then you come down on
someone's foot I mean I remember the
Kawhi Leonard situation here a couple
years up about two or three years ago
where that was a game changer for the
San Antonio Spurs and you don't want to
see you you want the health of the
players front and center and that is a
dangerous play for any player I think
any shooter or any player in plays the
game will tell you I'm most vulnerable
when I rise up and shoot I mean just for
an official to see Harden either shove
off and then create the space that now
defender needs to broach and him land in
it because he's kicking his feet out or
again it's a foul I mean for it it puts
a lot on the officials right yes J so
how does a league basically say this is
what it is everybody has to understand
well I think this is what we're gonna
have to figure out I remember there was
a player Reggie Miller who who used to
kick his feet out I mean not to call
names out that's okay BJ but no yeah
Reggie that was so it made the defensive
player nervous to close out on him
because he would kick his feet out and
then the referee would see contact but I
think the referees caught up to that now
I think the way the game is played on
when you're seeing guys shoot 50 60
times from the three-point line
the game has to be you know called
different I thought I think there they
are adjusting when I say they the
referees are adjusting but clearly you
want to have the health of the of the
off especially the offensive player
because of we know what can happen if
that player comes down on someone's foot
now we're gonna have you back on before
the end of the playoffs that's for sure
okay and again you've got your pure
hoops media pockets okay people can go
find that right now we're all podcasts
are found with BJ Armstrong that said as
we're sitting here right now team with
the best chance to beat the Warriors you
have the field okay or the Warriors I
think that the best team is the Warriors
as clearly we all let's say that we're
the Warriors beat themselves or it's
gonna fail I think the best roster
though is the Boston Celtics the Boston
Celtics 1 through 12 they are as good as
any team and I think this team is built
and they have a player who can play for
the full 48 minutes and create a shot on
its own and Kyrie Irving I think that
team there is gonna be a team to be
reckoned with because they are a great
team and as they as you go farther in
the playoffs this team has the depth to
play and win 16 games so and I really
like them so in the 30 seconds we have
left you full circle you said that
player to stop is draymond you said in
the commercial breaking yeah but the
Clippers with Jerry West who knows great
yes that's the team that did it best so
who won the Celtics is that Horford is
he the guy that they put on on him I
think they can put Horford I think they
can put Marcus Morris on them I think
they have a number of players that can
play at the speed of a player like a
dream on the speed I think can counter
whatever they're doing and I when I was
watching the the Clipper series the
Clippers to me with Jerry West and Doc
Rivers I thought they had a great game
plan good to see a bj PJ's gonna come
back on David Boreanaz Sean Payton in
your calls our two four more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app